today the Prime Minister is going to  Scotland Northern Ireland Wales and then  back to England were waiting for him  here in a demure so just been inside  Scottish Widows supremacy this is the  extent of the SMP protest outside our  body is getting ready with his kid we  are flying some alpha we found David  Blevins in Belfast looking forward to  the Prime Minister's arrival probably  looking forward to it more than most  people in Belfast and we're off again  this time to Cardiff in Wales  i'm here with online political guru Paul  war hello Anushka what are we doing  we're on our way to brains brewery where  we're going to see Stephen crab the only  man with a bid in the cabinet final leg  newquay this is rare and that's it